I spent the better part of a decade
looking at American responses to mass
atrocity and genocide and I'd like to
start by sharing with you one moment
that to me sums up what there is to know
about American and Democratic responses
to mass atrocity and that moment came on
April 21st 1994 so 14 years ago almost
in the middle of the Rwandan genocide in
which 800,000 people would be
systematically exterminated by the
Rwandan government and some extremist
militia on April 21st in the New York
Times the paper reported that somewhere
between 200 and 300 thousand people had
already been killed in the genocide was
in the paper
not on the front page it was a lot like
the Holocaust coverage was buried in the
paper
Rwanda itself was not seen as newsworthy
and amazingly genocide itself was not
seen as newsworthy but on April 21st
wonderful the honest moment occurred and
that was that an American Congress woman
named Patricia Schroeder from Colorado
met with a group of journalists and one
of the journalists said to her what's up
what's going on in the US government two
to three hundred thousand people have
just been exterminated in the last
couple of weeks in Rwanda it's two weeks
into the genocide at that time but of
course at that time you don't know how
long it's gonna last and the journalists
said why is there so little response out
of Washington why no hearings no
denunciations no people getting arrested
in front of the Rwandan embassy or in
front of the White House what's go
what's the deal and and she said it's a
she's so honest she said it's a great
question all I can tell you is that in
my congressional office in Colorado and
my office in Washington we're getting
hundreds and hundreds of calls about the
endangered ape and gorilla population in
Rwanda but nobody is calling about the P
the phones just aren't ringing about the
people and the reason I give you this
moment is there's a deep truth in it and
that truth is and war was in the 20th
century that while we had were beginning
to develop endangered species movements
we didn't have an endangered people's
movement we had Holocaust education in
the schools most of us were groomed not
only on images of nuclear catastrophe
but also on images and knowledge of the
Holocaust there's a museum of course on
the mall in Washington right next to
Lincoln and Jefferson
I mean it's we have owned never again
culturally appropriately interestingly
and yet the politicization of never
again the operationalization of never
again had never occurred in the 20th
century and that's what that moment with
Patricia Schroeder I think shows that if
we are to bring about an end to the
world's worst atrocities we have to make
it such there has to be a role there has
to be the creation of political noise
and political costs in response to
massive crimes against humanity and so
forth so that was the 20th century now
here and this is will be a relief to you
at this point in the afternoon there is
good news amazing news in the 21st
century and that is that almost out of
nowhere there has come into being an
anti genocide movement an anti genocide
constituency and one that looks destined
in fact to be permanent it grew up in
response to the atrocities in Darfur it
is comprised of students there are
something like 300 anti-genocide
chapters on college campuses around the
country it's bigger than the
anti-apartheid movement there are
something like 500 high school chapters
devoted to stopping the genocide in
Darfur evangelicals have joined it
Jewish groups have joined it Hotel
Rwanda watchers have joined it
it is a cacophonous movement to call it
a movement as with all movements perhaps
is a little misleading it's it's diverse
it's got a lot of different approach
it's got all the ups and the downs of
movements but it has been amazingly
successful in one regard and that it has
become it has congealed into this
endangered people's movement that was
missing in the 20th century it sees
itself such as it is the it as something
that will create the impression that
there will be political costs there will
be a political price to be paid for
allowing genocide for not having a
heroic imagination for not being an
upstander but for being in fact the
bystander now
these because it's student-driven
there's some amazing things that the
movement has done they have launched a
divestment campaign that has now
convinced I think 55 universities in 22
states to divest their holdings of
stocks belong with regard to companies
doing business in Sudan they have a
1-800 genocide number this is gonna
sound very Kitsch but it but for those
of you who may not be I mean maybe a
political but but interested in doing
something about genocide you dealt one
800 genocide you type in your zip code
and you don't even have to know who your
Congress person is it will refer you
directly to your Congress person to your
US Senator to your governor where
divestment legislation is pending
they've they've lowered the transaction
costs of stopping genocide I think the
most innovative thing they've introduced
recently are genocide grades and it
takes students to introduce genocide
grades so what you now have when the
Congress is in session is members of
Congress calling up these 19 year olds
or 24 year olds and saying I'm just told
I have a d-minus on genocide what do I
do to get a see I just want to get a see
help me and the students and the others
who are part of this incredibly
energized base are there to answer that
and there's always something to do
now what this movement has done is it
has extracted from the bush
administration from the United States at
a time of massive overstretch military
financial diplomatic a whole series of
commitments to Darfur that no other
country in the world is making for
instance the referral of the crimes in
Darfur to the International Criminal
Court which the bush ministration
doesn't like the expenditure of three
billion dollars in refuge
camps to try to keep basically the
people who've been displaced from their
homes by the Sudanese government by the
so called Janjaweed the militia to keep
those people alive until something more
durable can be achieved and recently or
now not that recently about six months
ago the authorization of a peacekeeping
force of 26,000 that will go that's all
the Bush ministrations leadership and
it's all because of this bottom-up
pressure and the fact that the phones
haven't stopped ringing from the
beginning of this crisis the bad news
however to this question of will evil
prevail is that evil lives on the people
in those camps are surrounded on all
sides by so-called zhengzhou heed these
men on horseback with spears and
Kalashnikovs women who to go to get
firewood in order to heat the
humanitarian aid in order to feed their
families manna Tarin a the dirty secret
of it is it has to be heated really to
be edible are themselves subjected to
rape which is a tool of the genocide
that is being used and the peacekeepers
I mentioned the force has been
authorized but but almost no country on
earth has stepped forward since the
authorization to actually put its troops
or its police in harm's way so we have
achieved an awful lot
relative to the 20th century and yet far
too little relative to the gravity of
the crime that is unfolding as we sit
here as we speak why why the limits to
the movement why I have is what has been
achieved or what the movement has done
been necessary but not sufficient to the
crime I think there are a couple of
there many reasons but a couple just to
focus on briefly the first is that the
movement such as it is stops at
America's borders it is not a global
movement it does not have too many
compatriots abroad who themselves are
asking their governments to do more to
stop genocide and the Holocaust culture
that we have in this country makes
Americans sort of more prone to I think
want to bring never again to life the
guilts that the Clinton administration
expressed that Bill Clinton expressed
over Rwanda created a space in our
society for a consensus that Rwanda was
bad and wrong and we wish we had done
more and that is something that the
movement has taken advantage of European
governments for the most part haven't
acknowledged responsibility and there's
nothing kind of pushback
up against so this movement if it's to
be durable and global we'll have to
cross borders and you will have to see
other citizens in democracies not simply
resting on the assumption that their
government would do something in the
face of genocide but actually making it
such governments will never gravitate
toward crimes of this magnitude
naturally or eagerly as we saw they
haven't even gravitated toward
protecting our ports or reining in loose
nukes why would we expect in a
bureaucracy that it would orient itself
toward distant suffering so one reason
is it hasn't gone global
the second is of course that at this
time in particular in America's history
we have a credibility problem a
legitimacy problem in international
institutions it is structurally really
really hard to do as the Bushmen
stration rightly does which is to
denounce genocide on a Monday and then
describe waterboarding on a Tuesday as a
no-brainer and then turn up on Wednesday
and look for troop commitments now other
countries have their own reasons for not
wanting to get involved let me be clear
there in some ways using the Bush
administration as an alibi but it is
essential for us to be a leader in this
sphere of course to restore our standing
in our and our leadership in the world
the recovery is going to take some time
we have to ask ourselves what now what
do we do going forward as a country and
as citizens in relationship to the
world's worst places the world's worst
suffering killers and the kinds of
killers that could come home to roost
sometime in the future the place that I
turned to answer that question
was to a man that many of you may not
have ever heard of and that is a
Brazilian named Sergio Vieira de Mello
who as Chris said was blown up in Iraq
in 2003 he was a victim of the
first-ever suicide bomb in Iraq it's
hard to remember but there was actually
a time in the summer of 2003 even after
the US invasion where apart from looting
civilians were relatively safe in Iraq
now who was Sergio Sergio Vieira de
Mello was his name in addition to being
Brazilian
he was described to me before I met him
in 1994 as someone who was a cross
between James Bond on the one hand and
Bobby Kennedy on the other and in the UN
you don't get that many people who
actually manage to merge those qualities
he was James Bond like in that he was
ingenious he was drawn to the flames he
chased the flames he was like a moth to
the flame something of an adrenaline
junkie he was successful with women he
was Bobby Kennedy like because in some
ways one could never tell if he was a
realist masquerading as an idealist or
an idealist masquerading as a realist as
people always wondered about Bobby
Kennedy and John Kennedy in that way
what he was was a decathlete of
nation-building of problem-solving of
troubleshooting in the world's worst
places and in the world's most broken
places in failing States genocide Allah
States under governed states precisely
the kinds of places that threats to this
country exists on the horizon and
precisely the kinds of places where most
of the world's suffering tends to get
concentrated these are the places he was
drawn to he moved with the headlines he
was in the UN for 34 years he joined at
the age of 21 started off when in the
causes in the war is de jure in the 70s
were Wars of Independence and
decolonization he was there in
Bangladesh dealing with the outflow of
millions of refugees the largest refugee
flow in history up to that point he was
in Sudan when a civil war broke out
there he was in Cyprus right after the
Turkish invasion he was in Mozambique
for the war of independence he was in
Lebanon amazingly was in Lebanon the UN
base was used Palestinians staged
attacks out from behind the UN base
Israel then invaded and over ran the UN
base surgery was in Beirut when the u.s.
embassy was hit by the first-ever
suicide attack against the United States
people state the beginning of this new
era to 9/11 but surely 1983 with the
attack on the US Embassy in the Marine
Barracks which Sergio witnessed those
are in fact in some ways the the dawning
of the of the era that we find ourselves
in today from Lebanon he went to Bosnia
in the 90s the issues were of course
ethnic sectarian violence
he was the first person to negotiate
with the Khmer Rouge talk about evil
prevailing I mean he was in the room
with the embodiment of evil in Cambodia
he negotiates with the Serbs he actually
crosses so far into this realm of
talking to evil and trying to convince
evil that it doesn't need to prevail
that he earns a nickname not Sergio but
Sir Bo while he's living in the Balkans
and and conducting these kinds of
negotiations he then goes to Rwanda and
to Congo in the aftermath of the
genocide and he's the guy who has to
decide huh okay the genocide is over
800,000 people have been killed the
people responsible are fleeing into
neighboring countries into Congo into
Tanzania I'm a humanity I'm Sergio I'm a
humanitarian I want to feed those I
don't want to feed the killers but I
want to feed the two million people who
are with them so we're gonna go we're
gonna set up camps and we're gonna we're
gonna supply humanitarian aid but uh-oh
the killers are within the camp's well
I'd like to separate the sheep from the
wolves let me go door-to-door to the
international community and see if
anybody will give me police or troops to
do the separation and the response of
course was no more than we wanted to
stop this genocide and put our troops in
harm's way to do that nor do we now want
to actually get in the way and pluck
genocide air from camps so then you have
to make the decision do you turn off the
international spigot of life support and
risk two million civilian lives or do
you continue feeding the civilians
knowing that the genocide air in the
camps literally sharpened sharpening
their knives for future battle what do
you do it's all lesser evil terrain in
these broken places late nineties
nation-building is the cause de jour
he's the guy put in charge he's the Paul
Bremer the Gerry Bremer of first Kosovo
and then East Timor he governs the
places he's the Viceroy he has to decide
on tax policy on currency on border
patrol on policing he's to make all
these judges of Brazilian in these
places he speaks seven languages have
been up to that point in 14 war zone so
he's positioned to make better judgments
perhaps than people who've never done
that kind of work but nonetheless he is
the cutting edge of our experimentation
with doing good with very few resources
being brought to bear in again the
world's worst places and then after
Timor 9/11 has happened he's named UN
Human Rights Commissioner and he
to balance liberty and security and
figure out what do you do when the most
powerful country in the United Nations
is bowing out of the Geneva Conventions
bowing out of international law do you
denounce well if you denounce you're
probably not never going to get back in
the room maybe you stay reticent maybe
you try to charm President Bush and
that's what he did and in so doing he
earned himself unfortunately his final
and tragic appointment to Iraq the one
that resulted in his death one note on
his death which is so devastating is
that despite predicating the war in Iraq
on a link between Saddam Hussein and
terrorism and 9/11 believe it or not the
Bush administration or the the invaders
did no planning no pre-war planning to
respond to terrorism so Sergio this
receptacle of all of this learning on
how to deal with evil and how to do it
deal with brokenness lay under the
rubble for three and a half hours
without rescue stateless the guy who
tried to help the stateless people his
whole career like a refugee because he
represents the UN if you represent
everyone in some ways you represent no
one your unknown and what the American
the most powerful military in the
history of mankind was able to muster
for his rescue believe it or not was
literally these heroic two American
soldiers went into the shaft building
was shaking one of them had been at 9/11
and lost his buddies on September 11th
and yet went in and risked his life in
order to save surgery but all they had
was a woman's handbag literally a bet
one was basket handbags and they tied it
to a curtain rope from one of the
offices at UN headquarters and created a
pulley system into this shaft in this
quivering building in the interests of
rescuing this person the person we most
need to turn to now the Shepherd at a
time when so many of us feel like we
were lacking guidance and this was the
pulley system this was what we were able
to muster for Sergio the good news for
what it's worth is after Sergio and 21
others were killed that day in the
attack on the UN the military created a
search-and-rescue unit and had the
cutting equipment the shoring wood the
cranes the things that you would have
needed to do the rescue but it was too
late for Sergio I want to wrap up but I
but I want to close with the what I take
to be the for lessons from Sergio's life
on this question of how do we prevent
evil from prevailing
which is how I would have framed the
question here's this guy who got a
34-year head start thinking about the
kinds of questions we as a country are
grappling with we as citizens are
grappling with now what do we take away
first I think is his relationship to in
fact evil is something to learn from he
over the course of his career changed a
great deal hid a lot of flaws but he was
very adaptive I think that was his
greatest quality he started as somebody
who would denounce harm doers he would
charge up to people who were violating
international law and he would say
you're violating this is the UN Charter
don't you see unacceptable what you're
doing and they would laugh at him
because he didn't have the power of
States the power of any military or
police he just had the rules he had the
norms and he tried to use them and in
Lebanon southern Lebanon 82 he said to
himself and to everybody else I will
never use the word unacceptable again I
will never use it I will try to make it
such but I will never use that word
again
but he lunged in the opposite direction
he started as I mentioned to get in the
room with evil to not denounce and
became almost obsequious I won here in
the nickname Serbia for instance and and
even when he negotiated with the Khmer
Rouge would black box what had occurred
prior to entering the room but by the
end of his life I think he had struck a
balance that we as a country can learn
from be in the room don't be afraid of
talking to your adversaries but don't
bracket what happened before you enter
the room don't black box history don't
check your principles at the door and I
think that's something that we have to
be in the room whether it's Nixon going
to China or Khrushchev and Kennedy or
Reagan and Gorbachev we get all the
great progress in this country with
relation to our adversaries has come by
going into the room and it doesn't have
to be an act of weakness you can
actually do far more to build an
international coalition against a harm
doer or a wrongdoer by being in the room
and by showing to the rest of the world
that that person that regime is the
problem and that you the United States
are not the problem
second takeaway from Sergio's life
briefly what I take away in this in some
ways is the most important it he
espoused and exhibited a reverence for
dignity that was really really unusual
at a micro level the individuals around
him were visible he saw them at a macro
level he thought you know we talk about
democracy promotion but we do it in a
way sometimes that's an affront to
people's dignity we put people on
humanitarian aid and we boast about it
because we've spent three billion it's
incredibly important those people would
no longer be alive if the United States
for instance hadn't spent that money in
Darfur but it's not a way to live if we
think about dignity in our conduct as
citizens and as individuals with
relation to the people around us and as
a country if we could inject a regard
for dignity into our dealings with other
countries it would be something of a
revolution third point very briefly he
talked a lot about freedom from fear and
I recognize there is so much to be
afraid of there are so many genuine
threats in the world but what Sergio was
talking about is let's calibrate our
relationship to the threat let's not
hype the threat let's actually see it
clearly we have reason to be afraid of
of melting IceCaps we have reason to be
afraid that we haven't secured nuclear
loose nuclear material in the former
Soviet Union let's focus on what we have
what are the legitimate challenges and
threats but not lunge into bad decisions
because of a panic of a fear in times of
fear for one thing surgery used to say
as fear is a bad advisor we lunge toward
the extremes when we aren't operating
and trying to again calibrate our
relationship to the world around us
fourth and final point he somehow
because he was working in all these the
world's worst places to all lesser evils
had a humility of course and an
awareness of the complexity of the world
around him I mean such an acute
awareness of how hard it was how
Sisyphean this task was of mending and
yet aware of that complexity humbled by
it he wasn't paralyzed by it and we as
citizens as we go through this
experience of the kind of the crisis of
confidence crisis of competence crisis
of legitimacy I think there's a
temptation to pull back from the world
and say uh Katrina Iraq we don't know
what we're doing we can't afford to pull
back from the world it's a question of
how to be in the world and the lesson I
think of the anti genocide movement that
I mentioned that is a part
sheíll success but by no means has it
achieved what what it has set out to do
it'll be many decades probably before
that happens but is that if we want to
see change we have to become the change
we can't rely upon our institutions to
do the work of necessarily talking to
adversaries on their own without us
creating a space for that to happen for
having respect for dignity and for
bringing that combination of humility
and a sort of emboldened sense of
responsibility to our dealings with the
rest of the world so will evil prevail
is that the question I think the short
answer is no not unless we let it thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a sports car yet a sedan
yet fuel-efficient
timers introducing the new BMW 3-series
our most advanced three
yet
[Music]